what's up dudes I'm gonna use feather
and welcome to hashtag news trending
right now on Twitter hashtag rejected
else names and have you met stabby gun
hands little guy can't get any work I
just want to make toys but he can't
because it's too dangerous than Santa
Claus won't let him top story you guys
epic Hollywood saga this is a melodrama
that plays out so deliciously there are
so many moving parts and little tiny
detail but I cannot wait to fill you in
20 minutes on the clock you guys you get
one no that's not gonna happen okay Sony
Pictures got hack and the leaks keep
coming you guys which basically just
reaffirms everything that we've already
known about any production company Sony
Pictures excluded no inclusion Sony
employees hate their bosses women get
paid less than men and why people make
racist jokes when they think that they
are alone but boys anger girls have you
read the email between Sony exec Amy
past now and Hollywood producer Scott
Rudin they keep apologizing left and
right for things that were illegal let's
be honest the only thing that they're
guilty of is talking exactly the way we
expect them to talk because these are
Hollywood producers what they write to
each other is like what the Mean Girls
wrote in the burn book in the movie Mean
Girls and it's exactly how a man
explains story to you chapter 1 haters
gonna hate it's no surprise to us the
[ __ ] popular kids love to talk smack
about the other popular guys oh hey okay
so Amy P was talking to Scott are about
DVF doing jobs like job no not that kind
of jobs the movie about the guy who
created iPhone cases or something I
don't know anyway is really the Jay
found out about it and was like no way
David F is totes mine he's directing my
Cleopatra movie so Scott R wrote that
she was a minimally talented spoiled
brat now I know but it was totes worth
it when Amy P ran into Angelina J at the
dance party and took this amazing bag
but then when Leo D
so that he didn't want to do jobs either
the movie you grow see any Pierrot that
he was actually despicable MEP is acting
like a total Amy B oh my gosh right high
five then when they replace Leo D with
Michael s yeah that Michael Allen Aaron
s the writer of the whole thing whoever
was like so in love with didn't want
Michael s he wanted Tom scene who is
kind of old but some kind of fun don't
tell anyone I said that but I have a
thing for him okay I wasn't gonna tell
you but I totally trust you so I'm gonna
tell you some stuff right now dish we
went on at all hit a rampage start our
wrote to LP about principal I mean
President Barack Obama that I bet he
likes Kevin H I guess because they're
both black that's dumb
then Amy P was talking to Clint C about
Kevin H and Clint said I'm not saying
he's a [ __ ] but he's a [ __ ] only in
Tom our head of Tristar production made
fun of this whole weird Smith kids thing
saying they are totally home-schooled
and don't let this family date your move
which you know totally means that he's
just gonna want to date him even more
and finally they all talked a bunch of
smack about that super emo director guy
can't receive and they think his next
movie is gonna totally second they all
hate him now but then it got super
awkward because at the same time Cameron
seasoned an email saying that he wanted
to direct the jobs movie and then like
no one replied and then like two minutes
that are who emailed again and like no
one replied super sad ok I never want to
talk about ever again
am i he's talking like that so chapter
two emo teen Diaries basically just teen
diary entries about how much the company
hates itself and how nobody understands
what they're going through
employees complain that there was a
general blondeness for the films we
produce and we continue to be saddled by
the mundane formulaic Adam Sandler film
and they eat their upcoming James Bond
movie which they are making anyway
actually they hate most of their
upcoming movies in general wow Sony
self-esteem much sounds like someone is
in that summer between ninth and tenth
grade when the only thing that makes
sense them is shopping at Hot Topic and
bringing more eyeliner for eyeliner
chapter three creative writing
apparently so
has plans to not only merge the 21
Jumpstreet men in black franchises which
Jonah Hill describes at clean and rot
and powerful but they're trying to do
not only one but two Ghostbuster movies
the OL female one which we already know
about which is supposedly supposed to be
Dreamcast but there is also a spin-off
buddy Ghostbusters movie starring Chris
Pratt and Channing Tatum - which
Channing Tatum responds with notice so
the rule the dark side and let us fight
it with all the glory and epicness fun
adventure craziness cool ball don't get
me wrong a mashup between Chris Pratt
and Channing Tatum makes me tingle a
little bit but whatever happened we're
funny guys being adorably schlubby now
they're funny and Jack I just don't
think that I'm ready to see yet stay
ripped marshmallow me you know what I
mean speaking of Channing Tatum's
creative writing this sour responded to
finding out that 22 Jump Street made it
to number 2 on the list of best ever
opening weekend for an r-rated comedy
beating out Ted fu Ted
second of all time [ __ ] come on chump
Streeters we got Kate Blanchet winters
box office [ __ ] I don't think I've
seen him explode like that since my
dreams of watching him and Magic Mike
okay you guys did I do that all in 60
seconds yeah that's my punishment we
have to read emails doesn't that big of
a deal there's really not that much fun
stuff in there oh how about this one you
guys don't understand okay it was
bunching in all the wrong places are you
sure it's not just a regular pillow that
you're using no all right you guys
that's it for me this week like this
view if you want to see a chubby
Ghostbusters movie and subscribe for
more hash tag news coverage also in the
comments below let us know about your
most embarrassing leak conversations and
what you think of Sony's movie plans I'm
Annie's further and I'll see you in
third period don't ever change the TT
way out slow
you see my hand